I was talking to Theo von the other day
but I was complaining because I had
gotten I spent $2,000 on back hair
removal mm we got to talk about this
yeah podcast we're on back camera laser
back hair removal and talking yeah weird
time it was not good you know I had been
in relation for five years so I didn't
realize it was bad to have back here cuz
you know when someone loves you they
don't care yeah and then when you're out
with these just regular girls on tinder
they're like to let you know like
yeah there's a problem I'll let you know
yeah like it don't they you know that's
not say no that's the thing hairy guys
it's like guys who are uncircumcised
having things like women love a good for
skin and they're like nope we're good on
that yeah so anyway I spend $2,000 it's
my 16th session I was like oh they'll
not really work and they're like yeah
you might just not be a candidate for
this and then I told Theo von he goes
man Jewish back hair is like climate
change I mean that's just gonna happen
it's [ __ ] but kind of brilliant
words why that works he used to have
that joke where he'd just go Jews across
clogging up the internet not only does
he have that joy I remember being on a
TV show with him called reality bites
back in 2008 and we were this and I was
just getting to know him and he's a show
about it was uh it was a bunch of
unknown comics Amy Schumer Tiffany
Haddish metrio Bert Kreischer a bunch
people are no longer in the business and
it was basically right when the writers
strike happened and Comedy Central
basically we just need something to put
on and so it was like let's just take a
bunch of comedians and put them in crazy
situations cool yeah it was it was fun
and then I'm ever you know it's when
you're just starting out comedy you
always trying out jokes on your friends
you know and Theo it shows me Iron Man
what you think of this joke Jews are
clogging up the internet and I was like
so it's a setup
right you're gonna be a punchline
comment or just oh that's the joke by
the way it works it works great only
Theo could pull that off
and how do you see edge with something
like that now it's just hilarious oh
yeah how do you how do you write that
and know you've written a joke like how
do you look at your writing pad and be
like sorry this is done it makes you
happen it makes you laugh
you know but you show your back here is
just free-flowing now but now it's you
know it's it's more like acceptable like
I was in my just got back from Miami
Beach last night and I was walking
around on Miami I was like I'm I'm aware
that I'm hairier than everyone else on
this Beach
okay blow up now in Miami no no I grew
up in Northern California in the country
Oh Miami Brian of all the [ __ ] City I
don't know I found from my you your
injuries to mine it drives me nuts oh
yeah I know when I say I have an EPROM
that I've been telling the listeners for
about six years that have an EPROM now I
just haven't done anything about it
so when I run so it might be from the
years of four fine now I'm sure your
trainer if he told me the same stretches
will do [ __ ] for me right I hear you
how'd it work for you how about when I
gave you instructions on how to sprint
because you were together okay
the way rocky does yeah we did and I go
you know when you he goes he ran anyway
I didn't realize he was running like
Sylvester Stallone does in the movie and
I went hey when you run here because I
took sprinting classes when I was in
high school yeah and I went run like
this and does make you faster right and
he goes oh hold on I'm sorry I because I
didn't work with the best
I didn't play football and high-level
and work with the best [ __ ] coaches
on how to run in the world and I didn't
do that afterwards either what were you
saying about because I wasn't running
like Sylvester on the movie exactly like
him you tell me I shouldn't roll him I
was actually embarrassed
we were we got embarrassed we were
filming friend kid 3d running on the
beach yes yeah and I decided to give you
a they did sprint total a snowman and
one see run perfect form when you're
making a comedy show game a boxing
lesson on set last yesterday and I had
to text Brennan just so I wasn't a total
[ __ ] Oh Stanley passed away this
morning Stanley had a philosophy behind
his characters you know Stanley had a
philosophy behind life
Stanley was a genuine real writer
there's a difference there and I think
one of the reasons that those characters
stick with us is they're conflicted and
they're real people they may be
superheroes but they're real rights a
spider-man with great power comes great
responsibility there was always a
philosophy behind it and the philosophy
was always pointing toward good
and wasn't I think you were talking
about that I think the reason the
Wolverine was the sort of the first big
hit because why do you know why no
spider-man was no no I'm saying in the
movies Wolverine was such a hit because
it was the first time that a superhero
that killed people
Wolverine killed people yeah most times
I would show expiring they were killed
and yeah well he pushed that guy that's
why they've always struggle with the
Punisher because in the comic books he
was just like I'll just murder people
all the time and they can't ever do that
no did you see the series of Netflix he
[ __ ] dude uh yeah I struggle I
struggle with that one but yeah not to
this most most hardcore fans think
Punisher should be like he should be
like a psychopath like he should be like
a guy who was like murdering everybody
yeah yeah those guys never they never
captured the wide embrace you know
there's still that idea of like super on
splatter your honor you're on it you're
on the way if you're on the side of good
which means you don't behave like your
enemy behaved right
you don't become them you always have
the higher moral ground and Stan Lee's
characters all have the higher moral
ground and held to it even when it was
inconvenient it's also it's fine the way
I think what Stan Lee was so good about
is like or any of the heroes that are
great is find a way to make them all
powerful but also super vulnerable yeah
like there's a reason Superman to the
originals was the best one because he
lost his powers and we could really
relate and relationship problems yeah
Peter Parker they all dead they loved
they had loves but they couldn't commit
because they had a bigger responsibility
so they were lonely characters they were
lonely
they couldn't ever have a girlfriend but
they wanted one badly because that man's
basically a stand-up comedian right just
always sort of a lone basically dude is
weird alerts at night only only at night
you know these overlays can relax cuz
he's always alone he's a baller The Dark
Knight was just a human he's human he's
not no Batman has no special plan right
zero range you know if his mom and dad
there's mom and dad died distant growing
on beam just feels so nice
that is just yeah
let's tell you piss your pants bro a
long time can I be honest because I'm I
feel like I'm in the circle of trust
right having the five tree I nobody's
listening no one's listening after we
finished filming on Monday I was taking
up hot piss and didn't get all of it out
and have this DUP the old snog in the
audience into my jeans yeah and I had
the biggest piss stain on my my pants
that's a problem I got my three-wheel
[ __ ] Batmobile like an [ __ ] yeah
I've had pretty embarrassing I've done
that before
well I'm like I'm gonna rush I'm like
well we're done I had more peeing
shafted yeah I'm like well there it is
now I'm all wet and jeans don't drive
fast
dammit greens take seven hours to cover
it take a long time to come here
[ __ ] you did Ken yes I was a 35 year
old man did that yeah my father was not
these jeans but my dad likes to used to
fly he had his own like a little small
plant here's a hobby of his and he said
I think you did this may said I got a I
got a I got a bathroom thing here I go
what do you mean he goes you pee in this
thing and I go well that's not possible
because I'm sitting down because now you
do it like this you ever done it he goes
nope I go I'll be careful because you're
flying and he'd were you know 10,000
feet up in here and he decided to try to
pee and it didn't work because he had it
wrong and when I tell you that he pissed
all over himself he emptied his bladder
laughing thinking about sitting down and
just basically peeing against
take a I don't know a cup and just pee
against the other side of it and and it
just it just was the most ridiculous
thing I was like well there it is and he
was just covered in piss I was like
enjoy this
can you ever piss in a bottle you'd be
surprised how much pee pee you hold it
oh dude I fill the whole [ __ ] tennis
ball of Gatorade things I've done in a
while you piss a lot yeah you have no
idea some when you've got you're holding
it yeah fires out like a super soak back
here like the first time me and Ashley
had sex we didn't use a
I just think we're like wow I mean we've
been together for over a year now so
like you know stay over a year yeah not
long okay it's been it's the other year
so I good it feels like 10 sure so we we
didn't use a condom and then I do this
thing like damn dawg where I won't use
account and I'll get super neurotic
about it and I'll be like terrified you
know so I made her go down with me to
Walgreens I've done this numerous women
where you buy the HIV home test if he
can't be four straight guys I know it's
very slim to vanishing especially if
you're European of Europeans isn't the
reason for that and I don't know if you
know this but at least this is from one
there in Enrique's who he's a venture
capitalist and I yeah but he was on TED
talk about this what they found is that
if you survive the vo banach plague
which is almost everybody you know of
the European extraction everybody you
know who has European blood survived the
bubonic plague was killed half of Europe
in some place was enough you have a
genetic predisposition there is a gene
factor where where you had you're
essentially HIV resistant meaning that
the only way to get HIV so why didn't
HIV become why was it in African
American disease why was to the East
Asian disease and why was it prevalent
in both sexes why in Africa was
devastating to both sexes why not in
Europe it never happened hmm because you
have a genetic predisposition you're HIV
resistant the only people that actually
got it were white men who were either
shooting up and getting a shot into
their veins or having or having anal sex
and being the recipient of anal sex the
men that were doing the [ __ ] in the
epidemic were the ones that survived the
epidemic so you made her take a chive
eat at Betty's do as many times she but
no one knows this exists and I actually
do a bit about this in my Santa bag
because it's so funny like this is how
little people use this product and any
walgreens are Duane Reade or drugstore
they sell an HIV test or you can find
out within 20 minutes just by putting on
your gums no blood to spit if you have
HIV but these are products are so
infrequently bought
they're always 50% off my question is
who's walking in there like oh I think I
have AIDS that's not marked down [ __ ] it
I'll find out
for HuluPlus I can't afford innovate so
I was all terrified and then I like made
her and that's what I knew she would be
a good girl for me because she could
deal with my [ __ ] your roses see
though I worry about HIV hehe like dude
you know and you bring her down
[ __ ] I would never I'd be like Matt
sorry I know it's not gonna be like I
will be bothered by it for six months it
will just crush me inside I've called
the HIV hotline so many times road they
literally toy like sir you cannot call
here for 48 hours because worried about
days they just get like I get like a
neurotic thing in my grade it's Linda
vanishing I know but I have to deal with
this beautiful woman who comes home
having just had her finger up like a
thousand [ __ ] with germs all over
and be like give me a hug in your
[ __ ] scrubs that probably have a
million [ __ ] father so yeah when he
came home and said that to me I said
fine you have to take one too and you're
gonna pay for it and then we did it it's
fine I was not planning on asking you to
venmo me 50 unless you were positive in
which case I would ask for the day I've
had guys you know like slip up in the
act and then like you have to go spend
50 bucks on a plan B and they're not
chipping in you know which is like in
both people's self-interest yeah when
you see my back I pull myself up like a
champ 30 times while talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gift it's a gift it's a gift